all right Catherine says I have a
question of how does one not buy into
the gentrification of American houses ie
purchasing oh this is good purchasing
the new granite countertops cupboards
new appliances etc I think it's an easy
thing to feel like you must up must
upgrade your quote old house built in
1996 when everything is perfectly fine
just not up to the standards of your
neighborhood mmm okay so two things
there if you want to upgrade do it for
you not for the standards of your
neighborhood yeah even if even if it's
like for aesthetic reasons it's because
you really you know enjoy how a granite
countertop looks versus the linoleum one
that's all chipped up I mean fine right
may the quote the real question is is
you know in that situation is can you
afford it and then is this the best use
of that money absolutely yeah and if you
can answer that great but it shouldn't
be man this is someone I really want to
fulfill someone else's vision of my
house right would this look go Instagram
is a bad reason to do anything you could
tweet that through Sean
you